[Music]
they may be small creatures but sea
urchins have become a big problem in our
oceans due to an ecological imbalance
they're devouring marine habitats off
America's west coast and elsewhere
around the world keeping other species
from thriving help may be on the way
from a unique partnership between
scientists and a seafood company John
Blackstone shows us how they're looking
to turn a menace into a meal off the
northern California coast
there's a crisis beneath the waves the
kelp forests seaweed that provided
habitat and food for much of life in the
ocean is gone wiped up by an exploding
population of purple sea urchins so has
this become an underwater desert out
here now this is mostly now a lot of
rock a lot of sea urchin and not a whole
lot of anything else since 2014 95% of
the kelp forests from San Francisco to
Oregon have disappeared at the bodega
Marine Laboratory research scientist
Laura Rogers Bennett has been studying
the spread of the voracious urchins
underneath is the mouth and there are
five white jaws in the center and they
can chew through rock I don't have to
worry about having them in my hand you
know five jaws all those you'd be in
trouble but we can pick them up no
problem
Rogers Bennett's as a warming ocean is
believed responsible for upsetting a
natural balance of ocean predators that
is allowed the purple sea urchins to
dominate and not just in California
there's other sea urchins around the
world but they're thriving too is the
oceans have warmed that's right as the
oceans have warmed the urchins seemed to
be the winners and they are really
thriving and taking off which is bad
news for the kelp forests but to brian
Takeda the CEO of a company called
atomic s-- all those sea urchins look
like a business opportunity so we
convert them from an ecological pest to
one of the world's most premium seafood
products or uni
in a matter of six to twelve weeks so
we're essentially monetizing the problem
species that you want to get rid of sea
urchins are considered a delicacy
particularly in Japan so we're genomics
is working with the bodega Marine Lab to
collect urchins in the ocean and then
fatten them up on seaweed pellets Carl
Minard
runs what amounts to an urchin feed law
part of the question here when you feed
them these pellets are they going to be
delicious themselves for us to eat
so far all indications are that they are
a very high quality and very delicious
Turnagain minutes into a meal that's
exactly right these urchins have been
fed for two months and are ready for
taste testing are you ready to try one
sure sure okay I'll give it a try I'll
start you off small there so we don't
overwhelm ya
yeah it's quite it's quite it's it's the
ocean yeah we want to get all this other
tissue out by next year or genomics
hopes to sell these urchins locally to
sushi and seafood restaurants and two
chefs looking to try new recipes the
Swan oyster Depot in San Francisco
serves sea urchin and welcomes a new
supplier you always have to have your
eyes towards the future and other
possibilities genomics is running
similar projects in Taiwan Japan Norway
and Canada which are all losing kelp
forests to urchins these are restorative
urchins meaning that the more virgins
you eat the better the environment
becomes so it's a very different value
proposition from all of the seafood that
we know of today virgin tommix hopes
Americans can be convinced to eat more
urgence before the urchins eat up even
more of a vital part of the ocean
environment for CBS this morning
Saturday John Blackstone Bodega Bay
California I'm fascinated by how they
get it out of there it's so good you've
had it I haven't had it I don't know you
got to try it
Jeff's taken us coming yeah have you got
to take that off yeah yeah I think he
was already cut in half when he was
still Mui what how about that nine lives
a virgin
you